Recall that we had four copies in
doing the client call, just transferring the arguments
from the client to the server's domain. That was the original cost. And the four
copies were first creating an RPC packet,
copying that RP-, RPC packet into the kernel
buffer. Copying the kernel buffer out into
the server domain. And in the server domain,
the server stub getting into action. Taking this
information that had been passed up to it by
the kernel, and putting it on the server stack
to start executing the server code. So this was
the original costs that we incurred in terms of
copying. Now, life is much simpler. All that is
happening is on the client side, the client's stub
is copying the parameters into the A-stack. And I
want to emphasize the word copying the parameters. That is
very different from what was happening over here. Here the
client stub was doing a lot more work. It actually
had to serialize the data structures that are being passed
as, as actually arguments into a sequence of bytes in
this RPC message. Whereas here, it is simply copying it,
because the client and the server know exactly what the
semantics and syntax of the arguments that are being passed
back and forth and therefore there is no need
to serialize the data structure. It just has to create
a copy of the parameters into the A-stack. And this
A-stack is, of course, shared between the client and the
server. So what the server stub is going to do
is basically going to take the arguments that are now sitting
in the A-stack and copy it into the E- stack.
Remember, the execution stack provided by the kernel for executing
the server procedure? That is a, the special
server stack that we're going to use. So the
arguments are copied by the server stub into
the E-stack, and once it is done the
server procedure is now ready to be executed
in the server domain. So what we accomplished
is that the entire client server interaction requires
only two copies. One for copying the arguments
from the client stack into the A-stack, which is
usually called the marshal link of the arguments. And the
second copy is taking the A-stack arguments that are
sitting in the A-stack and copying it into the server's
stack, that is the unmarshal link. So, these are
the two copies involved. One on the client side and
one on the server side, and both these copies are
happening above the kernel. It's in the user space, right?
It is in the space of the client that the client stub is making this copy of
the arguments into the A-stack. And similarly, it
is in the space of the server domain that
the unmarshaling is happening. And, of course, this
is the work done. So we're basically taking the
original four copies and gotten rid of the
two copies that were being done inside the kernel.
One into the kernel and one out of the kernel.
These two copies, which is done by the kernel, we
got rid of them. And instead, we have only two
copies. These copies, even though you're calling it copies, it is,
it is really not as tedious as creating an RPC
message. It is, it is a more efficient way of
creating the information that needs to be passed back and
forth between the client and the server using this A-stack. And
needless to say, the same thing is going to happen in
the reverse direction for returning the results. So it is just
that, it is, the server stack that is going to have
the result and the server stub is going to put it in
the A-stack and the client stub is going to take it
from the A-stack and give it to the client so that
the client can state resuming its execution. So there's two
copies involved in going from the client to the server, and
two copies involved in going back to the client from the server.